so we finally got an actual press
briefing from uh donald trump's press
secretary
kaylee mcinanny on friday and she is
apparently
just determined to humiliate herself as
many times as possible
in the uh eight and a half weeks that
remain before donald trump leaves office
she took
very few questions lied uncontrollably
and called a reporter an activist before
walking off
uh the podium every aspect of the
public-facing communications from this
administration have been
debasing the office of the presidency in
embarrassing and shameful ways and i'm
talking about trump's tweets
trump's press briefings his press
secretary's press briefings his cabinet
members like mike pompeo insisting there
will be
a transition to a second trump
administration
even though joe biden won it's been
pathetic
and it's been globally embarrassing and
kaylee apparently not doing what donald
trump has been doing which is mostly
hiding from public eye
she continues to go on tv and now hold a
press briefing
hugely embarrassing herself so let's
start with a huge whopper
from kaylee mcinanny claiming that
listen
uh trump giving joe biden a peaceful
transition
isn't the issue trump was never given a
peaceful transition
by obama or hillary i guess she means
imagine that and then listen to this
something that i would note is just we
talked a lot about
transfer of power and the election and
it's worth remembering
um that this president was never given
an orderly transition of power um his
presidency was never
accepted um in fact before uh
the election his election we know
crossfire hurricane was launched by
peter strzok to pursue a baseless
allegations about
the president's ties with russia that's
before he was president trying to
subvert
the will of the american people we know
in august peter strzok wrote a text
message about
an insurance policy against a trump
presidency once again trying to silence
the voice of the american people
um in 2016 we know in october that there
was a fisa warrant
a fisa warrant taken out to spy on the
trump campaign
then the american people spoke and they
spoke commandingly and electing
president trump despite
all of the odds it's hard to imagine
a more dishonest claim about how the
2016 transition went it's almost like
they don't recognize that there's video
of stuff
hillary clinton conceded the election
and called donald trump to congratulate
him
within hours of it being called barack
obama
invited donald trump to the white house
the day after the election
shook hands with him had him in the oval
office
and said i want him to do well if he
does well the country does well
barack obama went to donald trump's
inauguration
and shook hands with trump and then
gracefully flew
off in air force one this is just a
pathetic
lie and they don't even know what to lie
about anymore
kaylee mcinanni made no mention of the
fact that trump
lost they still don't acknowledge losing
here is reporter brian carram trying to
question
kaylee uh about this and she just calls
on somebody else
when will you remove the election kayla
at one point
the entire event completely farcical
here kaylee mcinanni smears caitlyn
collins as an
activist as she walks away after taking
just a few questions
or in 2016 and four years into his
presidency
thank you everyone for the very good and
substantive questions today
i don't call an activist i'm not an
activist and you haven't taken questions
since october 1st and you just took
about five haley that's not doing your
job
your taxpayer-funded job it's actually
hilarious
that kaylee says she won't take
questions
from kate uh from caitlyn collins
because she's from cnn and she's an
activist
and yet chanel rion from oan
gets to ask these conspiracy black hole
questions
and kaylee says oh chanel
is a journalist but caitlyn is an
activist i mean we're living in bizarro
world here quite frankly
uh caitlyn collins from cnn actually
summarizing it perfectly in a tweet
where she said after the press briefing
it's understandable why someone who
hasn't done
their job taking questions from
reporters in weeks
would confuse someone else doing theirs
with activism
this is really all just sad more than
anything and the united states is worse
off for it
we have to move past it we have to start
repairing the country
and this next story is about joe biden
trying to do that at least as he sees it
and donald trump just can't take it
getting very triggered over the weekend
once again